le président mes chers collègues
m'associer bien sûr d'abord à l'hommage
rendu à notre collègue olivier léonard
monsieur le premier ministre en ayant
aussi une pensée pour le brigadier
alexandre martin décédé le 22 janvier
2022 je veux également rendre hommage
aux 57 autres militaires français morts
au sahel depuis 2013 la déliquescence
des relations entre la france et le mali
est aujourd'hui plus que préoccupante
l'expulsion de notre ambassadeur
monsieur joël meyer née la dernière
illustration vous ne pouvez pas faire
endosser au mali seule cette dégradation
de la situation tout comme revendiqué
seuls les succès mais mutualiser les
échecs la france est en première ligne
il faut l'assumer certes l'instabilité
de la région népal de l'unique
responsabilité de la france mes chers
collègues mais le constat est simple les
menaces sont difficilement contenue la
déstabilisation de l'afrique de l'ouest
se poursuit après le burkina c'est
aujourd'hui le tour de la guinée-bissau
le président de la république n'a pas
cessé de fixer des lignes rouges qui ont
toutes été franchi force est de
constater aujourd'hui que face à son
impuissance la france n'a plus grand
chose à proposer le président de la
république a choisi le conduire cette
politique en solitaire au point que dans
la situation actuelle ministre français
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
navigue à vue dans la tente de la parole
présidentielle les français peuvent ne
peuvent se satisfaire de cette méthode
de gouvernance brouillonne nous pouvons
pas nous contenter d'une information
fractionné donné au fil des interviews
des ministres concernés il nous faut des
réponses claires sur la stratégie de la
france aujourd'hui dans cette partie du
monde monsieur bré ministre je vous le
demande quand allez vous associez les
français parlent représentés par leurs
représentants et consulter le parlement
sur notre engagement mali pour clarifier
la position de la france vous disposez
notamment de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution pour cela allez vous vous
en servir
pour répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne se présente
patrick kanner permettez moi au nom du
gouvernement tout d'abord de m'associer
également
aux propos de condoléances et de peine
que vous avez exprimées monsieur le
président suite au décès du sénateur
léonard monsieur le président patrick
kanner
vous avez raison la situation au mali et
au sahel en général et dans cette partie
de l'afrique est extrêmement
préoccupante je n'ai pas besoin de
rappeler ici au sénat que l'engagement
de la france dans ces territoires qui
date de plusieurs années est liée à sa
volonté de participer à la lutte contre
le terrorisme qui sévit dans cette
partie du monde et qui menacent
directement nos indien
s'agissant des situations plus
particulières du mali vous dites le mali
n'est pas seul responsable si monsieur
le président kader je m'appelle ce que
vous savez toutes et tous il ya eu un
coût des temps au mali à l'été 2000 20
qui a donné lieu à une jeune coup d'état
que la france et bien d'autres que la
communauté internationale cher présent à
condamner la même communauté
internationale à commencer par la cedeao
et les états africains ont demandé à ce
que la junte s'engagent le plus vite
possible sur un prix un processus
aboutissant à des élections pour
rétablir un fonctionnement régulier des
pouvoirs publics maliens
après s'y être engagée la junte malienne
vous le savez qui avait donné des délais
est revenu sur sa parole
cette même jeune malienne qui tout le
sénat le sait
a sollicité un groupe dont je n'ai pas
ici besoin de citer le nom mais qui
s'est déjà illustré dans d'autres états
africains par des exactions totalement
condamnable
et c'est cette même jeune malienne qui a
fait l'objet
d'une condamnation unanime pour la
gestion de son processus démocratique
notamment de la cedeao kiwis à
expulser notre ambassadeur
qui oui à expulser le représentant de la
cedeao et kiwi a expulsé dans le cadre
de la force takouba le danemark c'est un
pays qui s'isole qui cherchent la
confrontation
pour cela la position de la france
puisque vous m'interrogez ça a été
rappelé par le pana public c'est d'abord
comme toujours la recherche d'une
réponse multilatérale avec les états
africains principalement concerné et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec l'union
européenne et je vous rappelle que
depuis
l'engagement initial de la phrase 12
avons su fédérer autour de nous
plusieurs états européens sans compter
bien entendu le rôle des nations unies
avec votre autorisation président kaner
puisque je dois également répondre à une
question du président comme boum je
compléterai ma réponse dans un instant
sur le président keller
j'ai pas ministre manifestement le
prénom de république et vente au
gouvernement n'a aucune responsabilité
dans ce qui se passe au mali une fille
étions en responsabilité depuis 2013
aujourd'hui la situation se dégrade vous
ne voulez pas constaté le triple échec
du président de la république en matière
diplomatique mais aussi en matière
militaire en la matière l'heure du bilan
va bientôt sonner je tiens à vous le
dire très simplement ce que nous vous
demandons et vous n'a pas répondu à ma
question c'est un débat 50-1 pour nous
permettre d'avoir un débat de fond sur
la question du sahel dans cet hémicycle
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]